- All right,
So we just sit down.
- We're just gonna sit down.
- Okay, I've never done this.
I'm so intrigued.
I've never done anything like this.
- Okay, great.
So.
So there is a mother
energy that is present.
So, if you're mom is not departed,
it would be like a grandmother or an aunt
or someone that was like a mother to you.
- It could literally be any of those--
- [Theresa] Oh!
- 'Cause everyone died
before me, so.
(laughing)
- Oh, okay, but--
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But you're mom is here
in the physical world?
- My mom is alive, yeah.
- Okay, you're very fortunate
because you have not lost
a lot of people here in
the physical world.
- Yeah, I don't know many
people that have passed away.
- [Theresa] Right.
- So, yeah.
- Well, can I talk about
the dad that's departed?
- Oh, my dad did die?
Oh, I don't know him.
- Oh!
- Oh, yeah.
I'm sorry.
- Oh, okay.
- I was just going to ask you about pie?
- I love pie.
- That's what they told me.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- They go,
"Kelly loves pie."
- Oh, I love pie!
- Because, I'm like,
they showed me cherry pie and I'm,
like, okay.
What am I supposed to say with that?
I'm don't have a--
- Oh, that's funny.
Cherry pie is my sister's thing.
- Okay.
- But she's the one
he probably is trying to talk to.
- Well, listen.
- We don't know each other.
- But you have understand,
your dad could not take responsibility
for things in his life,
here in the physical world.
- Not a one.
- His soul is stepping forward and saying,
"I know what you felt.
"I know what you went through
and for that I am sorry."
So...
- Oh, I've already forgiven.
So, I'm good.
But I'm not, like,
mad at it, if he can hear me.
- No.
- Oh, I was like...
- No, no, no.
Like, that's not what this is about.
- Okay.
- You have to understand,
it's where someone,
if they hurt us or disappoint us,
only if the soul has learned
the lesson to see things differently,
they can come through and say that.
So...
- All right.
- That's all.
- I'll tell my sister.
- For your dad to be able to come through.
- Oh, yeah,
Candice did lose someone, yes.
- Who are you?
- [Candice] I'm Candice.
- [Kelly] She's my stylist.
- Oh, hi.
Nice to meet you.
- So nice to meet you.
- Oh my God!
The very first thing you said was mother
and I thinking my life.
But her mother recently passed.
That's right.
- [Candice] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Were you watching her breath in the end?
- [Theresa] Okay.
- So you're mom just said to me, she says,
"Please tell my daughter, I
know how much she misses me."
- I do.
- So know that you're mom is showing me
the breath--
- Oh my God!
- And watching you breath.
- I watched her.
- So she says,
"Please, I wanna thank you
for releasing my soul here in
"the physical world and
that was the hardest thing
"that you had to do was
to let me go."
- Yeah it was.
- Okay, okay.
- [Theresa] "And the way
that you fixed my hair
"and rubbed my face."
- I did, yeah.
"after I died."
- I did.
- She says,
"I want to thank you."
Your mom talks, though,
about her jewelry.
So, do you have--
- Oh (beep).
- Oh my Gosh!
- You just were telling me about
her jewelry.
- You'll have to beep
that out.
- She says,
"I want to thank you and I know."
- And I wear her name.
- Perfect.
- Every day.
I don't ever take it off.
- Did you take her blanket?
Well--
- I did!
Oh my God, I stole it!
(laughing)
From the house!
'Cause I didn't want
my stepdad to have it.
I stole her blanket!
(laughing)
- Oh my God, it's all coming out.
- I cuddle with it all the time.
- [Theresa] Perfect.
- That's so random.
- Because my--
- How would
she know that?
- Grandmother stitched it.
- I'm freaked out.
- Thank you so much
for your gift.
- Oh, you're very welcome.
- That was beautiful.
- Thank you.
- I needed it, desperately.
So thank you.
- Oh my God.
I'm here with Candice, my stylist.
I mean, so when you started
talking about the mom presence,
Theresa, I was like,
no, my mom's rocking in North Carolina,
she's good.
Like, I was thinking in my head,
but it wasn't me.
'Cause you kept looking off and you said,
well, maybe it's not you.
'Cause I'm looking off and, usually,
'Cause it means it's not with me, right?
- Right.
- And your mom.
You had, literally,
been going through this, like--
- Yeah, for the past year
it's been pretty brutal,
'cause she died unexpectedly.
So I wasn't prepared, obviously.
And I'd just had a baby.
And I had serious postpartum depression.
And so this last year was
a huge struggle not having her around
to be there with my newborn baby too.
- What did that mean to you, though?
'Cause, that was, I felt it in the room.
That was crazy
- One, the jewelry nobody knows about
because a family member
of mine wanted to keep it
and I was like, no,
I'm gonna take that.
It's my mother's jewelry.
My daughter's going to have that jewelry.
So that was--
- A bit of a klepto.
You got the blanket, too.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
See, that's the thing nobody knows about
is my grandmother crocheted
this blanket for my mother
and she always used it
on the couch reading
and stuff like that.
So, I kinda just snuck it--
- Oh!
- Into my wardrobe case at the funeral.
And took it home and I was, like,
told my husband's family.
I was like, I got this blanket.
But nobody, like,
I don't even, I think I
might have told his mom.
Like, nobody knows it.
And she was saying today, my mom was like,
I know you have the blanket
and I know that you
snuggle with it at night.
And that broke me, because you know,
I was on the fence at first.
I don't know.
But, like, nobody knows that.
Nobody.
I told my husband on the phone today,
I was, like, it was so amazing
and also really freaky.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Because my mom is,
literally, creeping on me.